tenemos entonces ahora estos escudos o
llamémoslo medallas de estrella ok y lo
que vamos a hacer con ello es pensar
cuántas estrellas de estas tengo
realmente tengo un grupo de tres
estrellas
así es que colocaré la siguiente
información tengo un grupo
d
tres estrellas
1 2 3 o lo que es lo mismo una vez el
número 3 lo pondremos así
por lo tanto tendremos un total de
tres escudos de estrellas o tres
medallas de estrellas uno dos tres que
pasa y vamos a hacer esto más
interesantes y ahora tengo dos de estos
grupos
vamos a considerarlo entonces como dos
grupos de tres de tres escudos cada uno
o lo que es lo mismo colocaré dos veces
el número 3
+ 3
podemos pensar entonces que dos por tres
es igual a tres tres o dos veces el
número tres sumándose
y 33 es igual a 6 de igual manera que
dos por tres es igual a seis ustedes
pueden incluso contarlos 123456 nuestra
respuesta es correcta vamos a
incrementarlo todavía más vamos a hacer
tres grupos de tres
esta vez tenemos tres grupos de tres así
es que colocaremos entonces tres grupos
por tres medallas o por tres estrellas
cada uno esto que será igual
esto será igual a repetir tres veces el
número 3 3 veces el número 3 2 veces el
número 3 una vez el número 3
vamos a colocar entonces 3 veces el
número 3 3 + 3
+ 3 y esto será igual a 9 3 por 3 es
igual a 9 o 3 3 veces es igual a 9 y una
vez más ustedes lo pueden contar si es
que así lo desean
tendremos 123456789 estrellas o 9
medallas con estrellas creo que ustedes
ya están viendo hacia dónde me dirijo
con esto vamos a seguir incrementando
los números haremos más espacio aquí
abajo
y ahora tendremos cuatro grupos de tres
listo tenemos cuatro grupos de tres así
es que consideraremos entonces 4 veces 3
y ustedes ya saben qué significa eso
significa que tendré el número 3 4 veces
4 y así puedo hacer mi suma que será 33
63 93 12
o puedo decir que 4 por 3 es igual a 12
o simplemente puedo contarlos 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 de hecho los invito a
que ustedes sigan con estas tablas y
poco a poco ustedes descubran cuánto es
5 x 3
cuanto de 6 x 3
cuanto es 7 x 3
8 x 3
9 x 3
y diez por tres les daré una pista antes
de terminar este vídeo
nosotros estamos hablando que aquí
tendremos cinco veces el número 3 es
decir 3
+ 3
3 por cuarta vez más 3 por quinta vez y
vamos a hacer la suma de 3 en 3 33 son
63 19 más 3 son 12 más tres son 15
los invito a que ustedes entonces
terminen con el 6 por 3 hasta el 10 por
3 una vez que este vídeo se haya acabado